I can't down before we even put the pen
to graph there'll be time to remember
little words like this right a little
but they carry one beat ya sir and write
n means actually you might have to put
this into separate a Pantheon I suppose
it means simultaneously true in other
words I need both of these satisfy every
value that I'll join shade is second has
to satisfy
another way which is you think back to
your age right
the train is a bit of a marker of
describing this is to use this symbol it
looks like down to you if that's what
intersection so the way you remember is
it's come at the end opposite is not
such a great word because I mean it's
not the officer like the Cobras right
incentives ending something else right
anywhere intersection now as opposed to
sometimes that is very sneaky actually
sorry if you look at the sheet you've
got I think all of them up ends right
it's it's like it you know ultimately
qualities are all the same time okay but
the alternative is all okay and by the
way obviously were the reasons why
sometimes are a bit picky like when
you've got two different solutions right
we don't like you to put a comma between
them because we don't know which one to
me okay cope in this example I'm and
wouldn't make sense something copy two
things at the same time but it could
mean either these that they mean
different things so instead of
simultaneously shirts all means you know
get me a red shirt or a blue shirt I
haven't necessarily how would you say
it's not necessarily song hae's the true
right I should say at least one is true
okay so it satisfies one or the other
okay and this is where the young I
suppose the different kind of Sanitation
comes in but where you could say this in
set languages I'll take the Union such
as upside down so you do for okay
alright so this question is finally
intersection of these two inequalities
find the intersection of these two an
alternative question would be by their
union of these two qualities okay we're
just doing with the intersection for now
you remember that to find the boundary
of an inequality you just take whatever
you've got and you just make an equal
sign so okay now the number line that
was just pointed but because he was
gonna have a plane x equals 5 is not a
point x equals 5 is alive okay now this
is a bit tricky in I'm trying to say
this is like oh I'm gonna put on lines
for all my boundaries
some of them will change I just need a
second well I'm gonna put x equals 5
always made about it there's one
boundary let's have a look at the other
one y equals sorry yeah no let's do y
cos 0 surf the x-axis
by the way if you are unlike me during
everything the same color right and
maybe this is like a constant problem
your asymptote is is invisible because
growing on top of your axis a way that
some people like to do it which is
totally acceptable is to actually put
your hands into it just above your axis
so you can see it but then label it as
what it is okay if it's like right on
top that's that's a minor detail all
right now you can see this breaks us up
into four quadrants okay so if X is
greater than five
we're going to be going in this
direction right so shade or if you've
got other colors there okay I'm gonna go
so I can not forget about the left-hand
side and when I say Y is greater than
anything I'm going off so within this
green section here the puppet I'll
double shade is
this machine but I'm not quite done yet
okay because these dotted lines these
boundaries right at least in this case
they should be included right so it's
not just X is greater than it's x equals
5 is also okay right so in fact where
this dotted line here is I'm going to
have to fill that in which is sort of
the sense of field so I'm gonna make
some in the same way the y equals zero
allegory okay
he's included right okay yeah over stuff
but let me just talk many boundaries you
can you see now you see why no I drew
them taught it in the beginning even
though I knew they should be included
why do I talk about it so exactly right
let's have a look at say this part of it
here okay this one equals zero at
boundary okay these products boundary
but it's not included in this inequality
because it doesn't satisfy both that
make sense it doesn't satisfy the X is
greater than 5 okay so it has to be
thought it right if I have two straight
line there I mean plane it's partly
recorded and just a minute what is it
where there's something um where two
months insect yeah this is now in this
case it is filled okay
it's filled because both of the
boundaries are filled right since I need
to satisfy both if just one of them is
not inclusive okay then this point won't
satisfy whatever so you only get a
filled circle when they were conclusive
okay if you're ever in doubt that's the
flavors if you ever ever in doubt you
just take these values and you test them
we both appear in accordance okay and
they have to do what big but that's it